et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec pierre emmanuel thomas de
professeurs en géopolitique et fondateur
d'euro continent bonjour monsieur hamad
merci d'être en direct avec nous sur rt
france alors beaucoup d'attentes un pont
ce discours est ce que l'on peut parler
d'une grande opération de communication
pour ursula von der leyen objectif un
tel exercice non de la coop et que tous
les européens a rencontré aussi à la
laque option 6-2 le vent trois priorités
affichées le pacte vers la révolution
numérique et la géopolitique
pourquoi selon vous pourrez ursula von
der leyen l'avenir de l'europe se joue
sur nicolosi et le numérique
alors selon mon point de vue de
géopolitologue je dois admettre que je
suis assez déçu par ce discours parce
que madame von der leyen avait promis
une commission européenne géopolitique
et je trouve que dans ses priorités
l'union européenne ne se renforce pas
sur le plan de la proche géopolitique et
j'ai l'impression que l'union européenne
n'a pas beaucoup appris de cette crise
sanitaire coville 19 c'est à dire la
même idéologie qui dominait le système
de l'union européenne avant la pandémie
est toujours poursuivi aujourd'hui et
cette priorité sur le climat par exemple
je trouve que ça aurait un sens dans
l'union européenne si cette priorité
pour le climat était mise en parallèle
avec une politique industrielle très
forte je dirais même à un
protectionnisme européen
une préférence européenne pour les pour
les produits fabriqués aux normes
environnementales interne
à l'intérieur de l'union européenne mais
on voit bien que c'est un affichage sur
le climat pour montrer dans le monde que
l'union européenne était en avance sur
les questions climatiques mais sans être
accompagnée d'un discours de puissance
et de mettre en valeur le marché unique
pour jouer dans le rapport de force des
puissances mondiales y compris en
fermant le marché lorsque les produits
ne sont pas aux mêmes normes parce que
l'idéologie de la commission européenne
évidemment c'est de toujours maintenir
de promouvoir la société ouverte une
union européenne ouverte avec des zones
de libre-échange dans le monde avec
comme ciment l'un multilatéralisme
c'est-à-dire jury 10,6 et toujours plus
les relations internationales et ne pas
pratiquer une politique d' équilibre
géopolitique dans le monde voilà
pourquoi je je pense que l'union
européenne n'a pas appris ducobu de 19
alors l'environnement évidemment ça
plaît à tout le monde mais ça permet
aussi aux politiques de ne pas être
[Musique]
responsable directement devant les
citoyens des résultats parce que c'est
facile de dire qu'on est pour
l'environnement mais par contre fermer
les protéger les frontières de l'union
européenne de manière beaucoup plus
ferme créer des emplois créés une
politique industrielle faire d'union
européenne
une vraie puissance géopolitique en
mettant beaucoup de crédit sur la
défense par exemple c'est beaucoup plus
difficile est d'ailleurs dans ce plan de
relance
on n'a pas beaucoup entendu les les
projets de défense européenne parce que
les crédits ont été diminués lors des
négociations
la crise sanitaire également
très présente dans ce discours et on
aurait pu penser que l'europe se
réinvente autour d'une politique de
santé commune pourquoi c'est compliqué
c'est compliqué parce que les etam les
états membres lorsqu'ils ont négocié ce
plan de relance avait des finalités
différentes
il y avait les fractures entre le nord
et le sud et entre l'est et l'ouest est
aussi une fracture franco-allemande et
donc c'est extrêmement difficile
d'arriver à un accord qui est là sur la
table mais évidemment il masque les
désaccords et en réalité cette ce plan
de relance et surtout un plan pour
essayer de sauvegarder le marché unique
et non pas pour relancer une europe de
la santé faire une europe une
géopolitique comme faire une europe
puissance comme il avait été promis
parce que les états membres n'ont pas
réussi à se mettre d'accord donc en fait
les crédits pour la santé ont été
diminués et d'ailleurs cela on se
demande si ça fait vraiment sens parce
qu'on voit bien que la lutte contre la
pandémie si au niveau de la l'état
nation qu'elle se fait ce sont les
systèmes de santé nationaux alors faire
des équipements construire promouvoir
des équipements dans des des équipements
communs au niveau européen on voit bien
quand dans un crise avec le d urgence ce
serait difficile de distribuer des
équipements surtout que l'union
européenne et ceir est d'émettre des
sans doute des des conditions pour pour
avoir accès à ces équipements
donc l'europe de la santé en fait est le
parent pauvre de ce plan de relance
comme je dis comme je les dis est là
pour sauvegarder le marché unique
et en plus il y a un prix important à
payer pour ce plan de relance c'est là
la rivalité franco allemande ou en fait
la france en fait a dû admettre
disparition du budget de la zone euro
alors c'est une grosse couleuvre à paris
donc personne ne parle
dernière question mais très rapidement
le site oman alors plusieurs dossiers
chauds attend de l'europe on pense à
l'immigration encore aubrac site lequel
justement de ces dossiers selon vous et
crucell pour l'avenir du vieux continent
alors je pense que pour l'avenir à long
terme du continent européen c'est le
dossier migratoire qui est explosif et
on voit bien à nouveau que l'union
européenne qui prétend sauvegarder la
sécurité des citoyens veut continuer son
son idéologie de la société ouverte avec
en fait une approche humanitaire l'union
européenne
au lieu de se construire comme puissance
se confond avec une ong pour exporter la
démocratie et pour aider les migrants et
sans se poser les questions
géopolitiques derrière ccc crise parce
que la crise migratoire est une crise
géopolitique aussi est évidemment le
break site c'est important aussi parce
que ça montre la fragmentation de
l'union européenne c'est un état
important une puissance qui quittent
union européenne et qui va apporte plus
de fragmentation au sein du projet
européen et d'ailleurs qui renforce les
les rivalités franco allemand sur les
finalités européenne et c'est ce qu'on
va voir dans les difficultés à mettre en
oeuvre ce plan européen donc l'union
européenne dans la partie difficile est
à venir et se sent pas une partie facile
parce qu'en plus tout le pourtour
européen est en crise du nord laisse
merci père emmanuel thomas d'avoir réagi
on dirait sur rt franc je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur de géopolitique et
fondateur du site internet euros
contient